[Applaudissements]
mais quelle mouche l'a piqué j'espère
que c'est pas un moustique tigre
vous avez sans doute déjà entendu parler
il fait peur n'est ce pas le moustique
tir et vecteur de la dengue de la fièvre
jaune du king kong ougna du virus 10 k
et malheureusement pour nous il se plaît
de plus en plus dans le sud de l'europe
aucun mur de la rate
il est désormais possible de contracter
certaines de ces maladies
en france métropolitaine c'est dingue
non
j'ai lu ça dans le journal il ya
quelques jours
neuf cas de dengue ont été recensés
cet été en région auvergne rhône-alpes
deux cas de virus zika le mois dernier
dans le var ces maladies que l'on
pensait confiné ailleurs rélégué aux
hôtes arrivent chez nous un peu flippant
je suis chercheur en informatique
spécialisée dans l'analyse d'imagés
issues de capteurs non conventionnelles
je suis aussi citoyenne du monde
préoccupés par les défis que l'humanité
doit relever dans les années à venir et
je pense que l'informatique est un outil
formidable pour répondre à certaines de
ces problématiques
je vous présenter comment nous
informaticiens nous travaillons avec des
entomologues pour développer ensemble
une solution qui permettra à tous d'être
acteurs de la lutte contre les diptères
hématophages
diptères d'abord indique terre est un
insecte avec une seule perdre l on pense
aux moustiques aux mouches autant on
estime que 15 % des espèces animales de
la planète sont des diptères 15%
hématophages signifie mangeurs de sang
les diptères matossage sont donc des
insectes à une seule paire d'elle
suceurs de sang
le problème pour nous humains etc à
sucer le sang d'humains et d'animaux
c'est diptères vont transmettre des
virus des bactéries départ est je vous
présentais quelques-uns de ses éditeurs
hématophages voici d'abord le fameux
moustique tigre aedes albopictus admirer
sa belle robe zébrée voici son cousin à
aider l'egypte si on sent comme un air
de famille n'est ce pas celui ci
transmet la dengue la fièvre jaune le
virus zika mais pas le king cunha un
tout petit peu plus sympa
voici un anneau félès ya plus de 400
espèces d'anophèles s et parmi celles ci
une soixantaine transmet le paludisme
par exemple à nous fallait cette fnci
ici en pleine action cette petite bête
crise là est un moustique commun culex
pipiens celui-ci ne transmettent pas de
maladies y vole fait du bruit nous
empêche de dormir la nuit nous pique ça
démange
mais finalement rien de grave pensez-y
la prochaine fois parmi les diptères il
n'y a pas que des moustiques
je vous présentais une mouche ou
glossines lamouche cité qui transmet la
maladie du sommeil aux hommes et au
bétail rassurez vous je ne vais pas vous
passer en revue les plus de cent
cinquante mille espèces de diptères ce
qui est important de retenir c'est que
différentes espèces de diptères vont
transmettre différentes maladies
d'ailleurs tous les dictateurs ne
transmettent pas d'ailés maladie de plus
en fonction des zones géographiques on a
différents types terres qui sont
présents on ne trouve pas les mêmes
espaces à cergy qu à sao paulo ou new
delhi par exemple je vais vous montrer
une carte de répartition du moustique
tigre le moustique tigre est originaire
d'asie du sud est
mais depuis une grande une grosse
trentaine d'années on le retrouve aussi
au brésil en amérique du nord et en
europe le diptère ne connaissent pas de
frontières pour migré d'asie
en europe les diptères voyage en
première classe
ils sont les passagers clandestins de
nos échanges commerciaux au hasard du
vol choisi le diptère va atterrir
n'importe où sur la planète
mais pour qu'ils s'y implantent pour
qu'ils y fonde une famille il faut que
les conditions climatiques lui soit
favorable
or avec le dérèglement climatique
ces zones favorables aux espaces donné
ils sont en train de bouleverser
il est donc important d'avoir des
méthodes de reconnaissance des diptères
sur le terrain
ceci va nous permettre de mettre en
place une surveillance d'un territoire
donné que ce soit à l'échelle d'un pays
d'un département ou de votre jardin
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on puisse
faire ça simplement avec un téléphone
portable
imaginez j'attrape on dit r je le prends
en photo
et là j'ai une application qui me donne
son espace résulte encore un moustique
tigre pratique pour paniquer encore un
peu plus en fait la façon dont procède
c'est qu'on n'attrape le diptère on
s'intéresse uniquement à son aile on va
le placer sur un fond sombre et là avec
des conditions d'illumination un peu
particulière on voit apparaître des
patterns d'irisation regardez plutôt
voici des winter fun fun pattern
interférences y ldl ou whip déjà c'est
assez joli
même le culex qui est aussi terme d
belle alternance de couleurs ce qui est
intéressant pour nous c'est qu'en plus
ces alternances de couleur ont le bon
goût d'être caractéristiques de l'espèce
données c'est-à-dire à partir d
alternance
on peut retrouver à quelle espèce
appartient l'ale ces images ont été
prises par mais en collègue
entomologiste
il en a pris quelques milliers l'idée
pour nous c'est d'avoir au moins une
vingtaine d'image par espèce qui peut
transmettre des maladies
donc à partir de toutes ces images on a
développé une méthode basée sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui permet à
partir d'une image de donner le nom de
l'espèce
cette méthode un taux de succès de plus
de 90%
ce sont les méthodes utilisées
classiquement par exemple l'analyse adn
ou la spectroscopie de masse ont des
taux de succès plutôt autour de 80%
donc là notre collègue et homologue
fiers de nos premiers résultats gagné
10% avec juste une image a été voir ses
autres collègues entomologues comme lui
on est rentré dans une boucle vertueuse
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont voulu lui
fournir d'autres diptères pour qu'on est
encore plus d'image et qu'on améliore
encore notre méthode
nous sommes désormais très proche nous
couvrir l'ensemble des diptères vecteurs
de maladies sur la planète
ces images ont été prises avec un
microscope classique ce qu'on imagine si
je dis microscope quelque chose d'assez
grand qui se manipule en blouse blanche
mais en fait c'est elle mesure pour les
plus grandes
un centimètre et quelques les plus
petites quelques millimètres on n'a donc
pas besoin d'un microscope ultra
puissant en fait un simple micro scope
usb portable de ce type peut suffire
celui-là je les payais moins de 20 euros
sur internet
il est grand comme ça et il donne des
images satisfaisante
du coup puisqu'on arrive à prendre les
images avec le téléphone portable
on a fait une application qui permet à
partir de ces images de donner le nom de
l'espèce auquel correspond l'aise ici
nous avons une glossines donc mais ce
qui est très important dans notre
application c'est surtout qu'on a une
carte de répartition des diptères qui
peut être mise à jour à partir des
résultats de la reconnaissance ainsi
qu'à partir des données gps du téléphone
notre application et le microscope forme
une solution portable de reconnaissance
de diptères cette solution peut être
utilisée sur le terrain par n'importe
qui ça peut être une aide aux
communautés locales pour reconnaître les
espèces présentes sur leur territoire
ceci devient donc un outil d aide à la
gestion de la santé publique des
organisations non gouvernementales
telles que l'om est ce par exemple
peuvent donc enclenché des actions
précises de prévention la tâche à
accomplir est immense la zone à couvrir
planétaire les maladies nombreuses
et les diptères toujours plus résistants
aux insecticides mais nous pouvons être
à la hauteur de cette tâche
entre 2000 et 2016
le taux de mortalité due au paludisme a
diminué de moitié dans le monde en 2016
le paludisme a même été éradiquée du
sri-lanka
aujourd'hui les experts considèrent que
pour venir à bout de ces maladies il
faut à la fois des investissements forts
et des nouvelles innovations
je vous propose une innovation à nous
tous des acteurs de la lutte contre les
diptères image of ages
[Applaudissements]